starke made you an Avenger the world
needs people like you how does the
family neighborhood spider-man sir
please you've been to space these
creatures destroy it in my world we have
to stop it here now
hey friends are in trouble what are you
gonna do about it I need a suit
everywhere I go I see his face
just really miss him I miss him too
I don't think Tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
gonna be here after he was gone
you gonna be a next Iron Man now well no
I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation heads up
Nick Fury's calling you I don't really
want to talk to [ __ ] all why because
if you don't talk to him and I have to
talk but I want to talk about you sent
Nick Fury to voicemail I got to go
you do not ghost Nick Fury dorks what's
up we're just talking about the trip I'm
here in San Marco Polo's oh I think MJ
really likes me my first alone you're a
very difficult person to contact
spider-man
this is mr. Beck we're gonna use someone
like you on my world new world Beck is
from Earth just not house the snap to
our home in our dimension we have a job
to do you're coming with us you can use
offworld captain burns unavailable
that poster from the neighborhood
spider-man [ __ ] please you've been to
space what do you want Peter
I want to go back on my trip with the
girl who I really like and tell her how
I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
it's always feel like I put my friends
in danger before the world needs the
next Iron Man you're going to step up or
not
[Music]
I work with spider-man who was there
spider-man I want when spider-man not
for spider-man
[Music]